à marseille maintenant un médecin
psychiatre a décidé d'apporter une autre
réponse que celle des éducateurs et de
la police au phénomène de la violence
chez les jeunes et même les enfants un
travail commencé il ya plus de 20 ans
caroline glorion michel anglade est ce
que c'est être violent à l'école des
pompiers est donné
marcel rufo et psychiatres pour les
enfants d'emblée il affirmé si on ne
traite pas le bourreau ne donne aucune
chance aux victimes
une formule qui cache un travail de
prévention auprès des enfants et des
jeunes
afin d'éviter ce que les psychiatres
appellent le passage à l'acte que ce
soit les coûts et aussi les crimes ou
les viols lorsque l'adolescent en
rendant un circuit de violence ou de
psychopathie ou de troubles de l'ordre
social
on a envie de dire que l'image du père
ne s'est pas assez construite mais en
même temps on peut dire qu'ils appellent
de psychothérapeute suffisamment qui a
eu l'éducateur suffisamment permanent
qui avait suffisamment un prenantes
mettre des moules sur la violence
permettre aux enfants agressifs de
nommer leur émotion c'est un travail
quotidien de psychothérapeute
une façon explique-t-il de retourner aux
racines du mal de les extirper avant que
les crises violences n'éclatent
mais marcel rufo ne se contente pas de
ces consultations dans son cabinet il va
aussi à la rencontre de ceux qui vivent
des situations extrêmes comme ici à la
prison des baumettes où ils visitent
chaque semaine les bébés nés en prison
pour ce médecin psychiatre il s'agit de
la toute première des préventions une
prévention indispensable
l'endroit est violent indiscutablement
et convenablement
violent les femmes sont entrées pour
violences et les bébés risque de ne
croire dans le fond peut être violent
petit être fidèle à sa petite enfance
donc au début l'enfant est fusionnel que
même la mère et l'enfant une personne
elles prennent certainement moins ils
voient que dire je n'ai seule voie qui
les qui lui ni autonome c'est un travail
de paris positifs sur l'avenir des
enfants de prison et de paris pour
couper les trajectoires répétitives ton
père a été un assassin qui sont un
assassin tu ta mère a fait des exactions
qui commettra ces exactions
c'est vraiment une goutte aux américains
tout ce que je fais avec ses bébés mais
si la mère s'est fait de multiples
boutons l'heure c'est contre l'engrenage
de la violence quotidienne que marcel
rufo se bat et ses armes à lui sont le
dialogue l'écoutent et beaucoup
d'humanité et ce documentaire de 50
minutes dans son entier sera diffusée
samedi à 13h40 d'en savoir plus
santé